اسرائيل تعلن عمليتها البريه لاجتياح غزه
فيما واشنطن تصرح المقاومه الفلسطينيه قد
تباغت الجيش الاسرائيلي وحل اسرائيلي
لقطاع غزه لكن هل تقبل به مصر 45 طائره
شحن امريكيه تحمل ال طن من الاسلحه لتل
ابيب المقاومه تستجيب لطلب امريكي بوسطه
قطريه اتصال تركي مصري لاجل غزه والسيسي
يحذر بريطانيا السعوديه تطالب بحدود 67
فلسطينيه المقاومه تبلغ تل ابيب بقبول
الافراج عن الاسرى ما هي الشروط القاهره
تدين الغرب قائله هي ليست مسؤوليتنا
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل تناقشان الرد
على لبنان بينما الحكومه اللبنانيه تحضر
خطه طوارئ عاجله الجيش الاسرائيلي يجلي
مستوطنات جديده والامريكان يرفضون سياسه
بايدن
الاجتياح يقترب طال الوقت ام قصر اسرائيل
اعلنت وتعلن وستعلن عن عمليتها المنتظره
لاجتياح غزه وسافر الاسرائيلي ولدى روسيا
الكساندر بنتسك يصرح لوكاله تاس بان
اسرائيل قررت اطلاق عمليه بريه في قطاع
غزه وذلك لتدمير جميع الهياكل المقاومه
واطلاق سراح الرهائن وبالتالي لا يمكن
القيام بذلك دون اللجوء للعمليه البريه
بحسب تعبيره وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي دانييل الجاري قال ان الهجمات
التي يشنها سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي في قطاع
غزه لم يسبق لها مثيل منذ عقود وهي ربما
تكون اشاره الى شن العمليه البريه
المحتمله ضد القطاع لكن من جهه اخرى صرح
كبير مستشاري رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
مارك ريغيف لقناه الجزيره ان اسرائيل تعرف
انها ستدفع الثمن وان عددا من شبانها لن
يعودوا وها نحن نتصفح المصدر هذا ونشرت
صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه تحقيقا بشان
انواع من الاسلحه قد تمتلكها المقاومه
واشار التقرير الى ان قدرات المقاومه
العسكريه قد تباغت القوات الاسرائيليه في
حال شنت هجوما بريا على غزه هنا رجل
الاعمال والاكاديمي الاسرائيلي الان جانور
يصرح في مقال له بصحيفه كالكاليست
الاقتصاديه الاسرائيليه ان الحل الوحيد
لحل مشكله قطاع غزه بالنسبه الى اسرائيل
هو اعادته الى مصر اما الدعم الامريكي فلا
يتوقف حيث اعلن المتحدث باسم البنتاجون
باتريك رايدر ان واشنطن ترسل مساعدات
عسكريه لاسرائيل بشكل شبه يومي تتضمن
قنابل موجهه وقذائف وصواريخ اعتراضيه
لمنظومه القبه الحديديه للدفاع الجوي وهو
ما نقلته وكاله لنضل عن وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه بان 45 طائره شحن تحمل 1ف ط
من الاسلحه وصلت الى اسرائيل منذ بدء
الحرب في السابع من اكتوبر الجاري مازلنا
في الولايات المتحده حيث اظهر استطلاع
للراي اجرته شبكه سي بي سي ان غالبيه
الامريكيين لا يوافقون على سياسات الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن فيما يتعلق بالصراع بين
اسرائيل والمقاومه واظهر الاستطلاع ان
56% من المشاركين لا يوافقون على تعامل
بايدن مع التصعيد في الشرق الاوسط فيما
وصلت نسبه عدم موافقه بين الناخبين
الجمهوريين الى
72% بعد جهود قطريه اعلن الناطق باسم
المقاومه ابو عبيده انهم اطلقوا راح
المحتجزين الامريكيتين ام وابنتها لدواع
انسانيه ليثبتوا للشعب الامريكي والعالم
ان ادعاءات بايدن وادارته هي ادعاءات
كاذبه وفق تعبيره فيما افادت قناه بي بي
سي بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ابلغت اسرائيل
باستعدادها لاطلاق سراح بعض الاسرى الذين
تحتجزهم مقابل وقف فوري لاطلاق النار هل
تقبل اداره نتنياهو في المواقف الدوليه
وخلال افتتاح القمه الاولى بين دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ورابطه دول جنوب شرقي
اسيا ايجن دع ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان الى اقامه دوله فلسطينيه
وفق حدود 67 بما يحقق الامن والازدهار
للجميع معتبرا ان العنف في غزه يدفع ثمنه
المدنيون الابرياء ليبلغ الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي رئيس وزراء بريطانيا
ريشي سوناك بانه من المهم التدخل بشان غزه
حتى لا يتسبب هذا الامر في سقوط الكثير من
المدنيين مؤكدا على ضروره التنسيق بين
الدول لعدم انزلاق المنطقه الى حرب شامله
السيسي يعا ليجري محادثات هاتفيه مع
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ليتفق
الرئيسان على انه لا يمكن القبول باجبار
الفلسطينيين على الهجره وال لجوء من غزه
من مصر ايضا دعا الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو وتريش عقب وصوله مدينه
رفح المصريه الى وقف اطلاق نار انساني في
غزه وقال جوتش نعمل بشكل فعال مع مصر
واسرائيل وامريكا لادخال المساعدات في
اقرب وقت ممكن ووصف ادخال المساعدات الى
اكثر من مليوني شخص دون ماء او طعام او
وقود في قطاع غزه بانه الفارق بين الحياه
والموت للكثير
فيما تم تنظيم مظاهرات غاضبه وحشده في قلب
القاهره دعت الى تدخل عسكري للجيوش
العربيه لوقف الهجوم الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه من جهته استقبل الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي شارل ميشيل
وارسلا فوندر لاين في قمه تسعى الى توجيه
رساله وحده بشان دعم اسرائيل واوكرانيا
على حد سواء لتعلن وزيره الهجره السويديه
ماريا ممر ستينر جارد ان سلطات بلادها قد
تلج الى ترحيل الاشخاص المتعاطفين مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في المستقبل من
اراضيها اما وزاره الداخليه الالمانيه
فاعلنت انها ستقوم بترحيل انصار المقاومه
اذا اضطرت لذلك اليكم المصدر تعلن وزيره
الهجره السويديه ماريا مالم ستينر جارد ان
سلطات بلادها قد تلجا الى ترحيل الاشخاص
المتعاطفين مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
المستقبل من اراضيها اما وزاره الداخليه
الالمانيه فاعلنت انها ستقوم بترحيل انصار
المقاومه اذا اضطرت لذلك ميدانيا اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه شن اكثر من 100 غاره
على مواقع عده في غزه فيما قال نائب رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي في الاحتياط اير
جولان ان تدمير غزه سيضر بجهود الجيش لان
مقاتلي المقاومه ينتظرونهم تحت الارض فيما
قال جهاز الامن الاسرائيلي شاباك لشبكه سي
ان ان انه اعتقل المتحدث باسم المقاومه في
الضفه الغربيه حسن يو يوسف خلال مداهمات
نفذتها القوات الاسرائيليه في انحاء الضفه
لننتقل الى الحدود اللبنانيه بموافقه وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف جالنت اعلنت الهيئه
الوطنيه لاداره الطوارئ التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع نيما والجيش الاسرائيلي عن اجلاء
سكان مدينه كريات شمون الشماليه الى دور
الضيافه التي تدعمها الدوله فيما كانت
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه اعلنت اجلاء
27000 اسرائيلي من 28 بلده حدوديه في
الجليل ها هو المصدر يتحدث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه عن خطه لاجلاء سكان
بلده كريات شموه القريبه من الحدود
اللبنانيه واعلنت سلطات الاسرائيليه اجلاء
السكان على طول حدودها الشماليه مع لبنان
بعد اغلاق المنطقه اثر استمرار القصف
المتبادل مع حزب الله وفصائل فلسطينيه
داخل لبنان بينما كشف تقرير لموقع اكسيوس
ان واشنطن تبحث مع اسرائيل امكانيه التدخل
العسكري ضد مقاومه لبنان على انخراطها في
الحرب الدائره بين اسرائيل وفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هناك صرح رئيس
الحكومه اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي قائلا نعد
خطه طوارئ تحسبا لاي مستجدات مضيفا نجري
اتصالات دبلوماسيه وسياسيه لمعالجه
الاوضاع ووقف الهجوم الاسرائيلي على
اراضينا خلال ذلك قالت المقاومه اللبنانيه
ان قواتها استهدفت بالصواريخ الموجهه موقع
هرمون المقابل لبلده رميش كما قصفت خمسه
مواقع اسرائيليه في تلال كفرشوبا ومزارع
شبعه اللبنانيه واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه رصد اطلاق نحو 20 قذيفه صاروخيه من
الاراضي اللبنانيه تجاه اسرائيل بالعوده
الى مصر ادانت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه
قيام الاعلام الغربي باستهداف مصر منذ
بدايه الازمه في قطاع غزه مؤكده ان مصر
ليست مسؤوله عن عرقله خروج الرعي الاجانب
مضيفه المعبر مفتوح ومصر ليست مسؤوله عن
عرقله
[موسيقى]
خروجهم